i love serverless computing but back in  december 2021 i shared a dirty little  secret i dislike the word serverless  i asked for your help to find a new word  and you delivered  some of you suggested describing the  servers there were some good suggestions  others pointed out that we have good  terms already that we could use or adapt  i like that  some of you wanted to highlight the  benefits of serverless that is a really  good idea  but the ones that stuck with me were the  ones that use the word managed someone  else is managing your service it can be  applied to computing or databases or  machine learning or any other managed  service from the cloud  so should we rename this video series to  managed expeditions  i'll stick with serverless expeditions  for now  but i will use the word managed in  meetings and emails from now on  thank you for finding a great new word  for serverless